If the learning goals
are what you should know,
and the learning outcomes are what
you should be able to do.
Then the learning assessments
are how we assess whether or
not you know what you need to know.
And can do what you need to be able
to do by the end of this course.
Here the assessments are going
to be very authentic.
The overall outcome we aim for
is that you should be able to contribute
to the field of educational technology.
So the assessment will
be based on whether or
not you contributed to the field
of educational technology.
You'll build a tool, conduct some
research, evaluate some technology.
But by the end of this course
you'll have actually contributed to
the community of educational technology.
Now, there will be a lot of
milestones along the way.
Before you can get to your contribution,
you need to demonstrate
your mastery of some topic.
You need to propose your idea.
You need to execute your plan, and then
you need to deliver your final results.
By the end of it you will have created
a real contribution to the educational
technology community.